mehr als sieben Monate Krieg in der
Ukraine und auch heute wollen wir uns
die militärische Lage im Land ansehen
die ukrainische Armee nach ihrem Vorstoß
in der Region rakiv im Nordosten des
Landes hat eine neue Offensive begonnen
und rückt weiter gegen russische Truppen
vor und diese neue Offensive ist da wo
die Russen es am wenigsten erwarten und
auch am wenigsten wollen nämlich in der
Region Donezk hier im Süden von Donalds
bzw im Südosten Nord von Donuts und
Südosten von rakiv gehen ukrainische
Einheiten weiter vor und haben in den
letzten Tagen mehrere Dörfer erobert und
wir haben auch erste Aufnahmen die uns
das ganze zeigen Aufnahmen aus dem Dorf
jetzt kiefka und jetzt kiefka ist ein
Dorf tatsächlich in Donuts also in
dieser sogenannten Volksrepublik wo
Putin gerade ein Referendum zum
Anschluss an Russland durchführen lässt
aber auch Donuts wird derzeit von der
Ukraine zurückerobert immer mehr Teile
davon wir sehen hier ukrainische
Einheiten die sich dadurch bewegen jetzt
hier eine
Bahnlinie überqueren und wir können
nochmals am Ende mal ansehen von wo das
ganze gefilmt ist nämlich von panzerten
Fahrzeug das ist in diesem Fall kein
Panzer oder Schützenpanzer sondern ein
sogenannter sa8 also einen
flugabwehrgeschütz wir sehen das jetzt
wenn sich umdreht wir können uns das mal
ganz genau ansehen und zwar da oben
sehen wir hier kommen theoretisch die
Raketen raus das eine Aufnahme von
wahrscheinlich vorgestern die erst
gestern veröffentlicht wurde aus
Sicherheitsgründen und die Rosen hätten
gewarnt sein können waren sie aber nicht
denn sie haben versucht diese Offensive
aufzuhalten indem sie massiv ihre
Luftwaffe geschickt haben in die Region
und wir sehen jetzt hier wie ukrainische
Soldaten gerade ihre verschiedenen
Flugabwehrgeschütze nutzen und ein
erstes Flugzeug hier sehen wir die
Explosion abschießen der Russen aber das
ist nicht das einzige Flugzeug sondern
nach ukrainischen Angaben wurden gestern
vier Flugzeuge abgeschossen wir haben
jetzt ein weiteres Video was von einer
Drohne aufgenommen wurde aus der
gleichen Region auch hier sehen wir ein
russisches Flugzeug was fliegt was dann
eben getroffen wird wir sehen uns gleich
eine Explosion und was dann zu Boden
stürzt da die Explosion am Flugzeug was
jetzt zu Boden stürzt und in einem
riesigen Feuerball hier aufgeht das also
ein zweites Flugzeug was abgeschossen
wurde und es geht weitere Aufnahmen
einer zu 30 einer sehr modernes
russisches Kampfflugzeug was ebenfalls
getroffen wurde von der ukrainischen
Luft Abwehr aber es offenbar geschafft
hat noch mit brennenden Triebwerken
weiter zu fliegen und wieder zurück nach
Russland zu entkommen die Aufnahmen
starten jetzt sofort hier sehen wir das
Flugzeug wir können das einmal kurz
anhalten um das auch kurz im Bild zu
sehen hier also sehr gut zu erkennen
eine su30 ein zu hoi Kampfflugzeug was
ihr mit einem brennenden Triebwerk
fliegt und zumindest in diesem Video
nicht abstürzt wir gehen davon aus dass
dieses Flugzeug zwar getroffen wurde
aber schwer beschädigt es zurück nach
Russland geschafft hat das heißt vier
russische Kampfflugzeuge die allein
gestern über der Region Donezk
abgeschossen wurden Russland scheint
offenbar noch immer nicht den Ernst der
Lage erkannt zu haben dass die
ukrainische Luft Abwehr nämlich mit all
dem was sie auch von Westen bekommen hat
völlig überlegen ist der russischen
Luftwaffe was machen die Russen ja sie
gehen weiter mit Terror vor gegen die
Ukraine nämlich mit Drohnen Terror hier
Aufnahmen von heute morgen aus Odessa
das eine Shahid 136 Drohne eine
kamikazegrund Drohne der iranischen
Armee die in den letzten Wochen wohl zu
Hunderten nach Russland verkauft wurden
und wir sehen uns einfach mal an wie
diese Drohne dann leider auch in Odessa
einschlägt sie geht also hier runter wir
haben es unten geblirrt weil wir nicht
genau verraten wo das ist und hier sehen
wir eine riesige Explosion auf einem
Hochhaus jetzt sind wir auch den Rauch
das also eine der drohen hier
eingeschlagen ist mindestens die fünfte
dieser gestern und besser eingeschlagen
ist auch dieses Ziel hier soll
militärisch gewesen sein nämlich das
Hauptquartier des südlichen Kommandos
der ukrainischen Armee nichtsdestotrotz
wir hören das vielleicht im Hintergrund
die Leute sind hier schockiert die sind
terrorisiert wir hören Leute und Frauen
die auf beiden und nicht nur diese
Drohnen diese Shahid 186 sondern auch
sehr große iranische kampfdrohen hier
die mutterher 6 scheint der Iran
gesendet zu haben denn diese Aufnahmen
hier aus dem Schwarzen Meer zeigen eine
abgeschossene Mutterherz Drone eine sehr
große Drohne mit 10 Meter sehr
Spannweite und sechs Meter Länge die
auch mit Raketen bewaffnet werden kann
die wurde abgeschossen von der
ukrainischen Küstenwache und wurde er
dann hier im Meer geborgen von einem
ukrainischen Schiff das heißt wir gehen
davon aus dass mittlerweile tatsächlich
hunderte iranische Kampfdrohnen im
Einsatz sind für die russische Armee und
dass sich Putin so immer mehr auf die
Mullahs verlässt um eben die Ukraine mit
iranisch Waffen mit Terror zu überziehen
[Musik]